- [Narrator] Have you
ever seen the full moon
appear to change from this,
to this, to this
all in a couple hours?
If so, you've witnessed a lunar eclipse.
The word eclipse comes from a Greek word
meaning "to leave."
For centuries, people have marveled
at how the full moon appears to leave
during a lunar eclipse.
The Incas believed that
lunar eclipses happened
when a giant jaguar ate the full moon.
It turns out, lunar eclipses happen
when the moon is covered
by Earth's shadow.
We can only see the moon
because it reflects light from the sun.
The moon doesn't generate
any light of its own.
The sun lights up half of
the sphere of the moon.
When Earth is between
the sun and the moon,
we can see the entire
lit part of the moon.
We call this the full moon.
But sometimes during a full moon,
Earth, the moon, and the sun all line up
in such a way that Earth
casts a shadow onto the moon.
This creates a lunar eclipse.
Lunar eclipses can be seen
from anywhere on the night side of Earth.
The two most dramatic
types of lunar eclipses
are total and partial.
During a total lunar eclipse,
Earth's shadow completely covers the moon.
This means that no direct
sunlight is reaching the moon.
However, the moon is still
visible during the eclipse.
Why is this?
As sunlight passes through our atmosphere,
some of it gets bent slightly
allowing it to reach the moon
as indirect sunlight.
Most of the light that
gets bent is red or orange,
meaning that the moon
appears reddish orange
during the eclipse.
During a partial lunar eclipse,
Earth's shadow only
partially covers the moon.
So some direct sunlight is
still reaching the moon.
Lunar eclipses only
happen during a full moon
since it's the only
time in the moon's orbit
where Earth is between
the sun and the moon.
And you might be wondering,
"why isn't there a lunar eclipse
during every full moon?"
Well, the moon's orbit around Earth
is tilted relative to
Earth's orbit around the sun.
This means that the moon
often passes just above or
just below Earth's shadow.
Partial lunar eclipses
happen when the sun,
the moon, and Earth almost,
but not quite exactly,
line up so that the moon
is only partially covered
by Earth's shadow.
Total lunar eclipses
happen only when the sun,
the moon, and Earth all line up precisely.
So if you ever get to see a lunar eclipse,
you can thank our planet for
blocking the moon's sunlight
and letting us enjoy
the celestial spectacle.